a beta test refers to the distribution
of pre-release game software to a
selected group of people so that they
can test the game in their own homes the
beta version of the game is as close to
perfect as the company can make it but
any bugs glitches or other issues
discovered in beta testing will usually
be addressed before the game's official
release take a pedia 2017 we'll start
this off by going over the game modes
that are available in the beta unloading
into the game you have to choose out of
the three class types Titan
Hunter and walk your Lantern straight
into an all-too-familiar cutscene set to
the current situation before starting
the first story mission the game playing
graphics look ok but essentially no
different than destiny 1 they have the
same look and feel with the only
noticeable difference being that there
seems a little more going on in the
background with extra machines and other
environmental pieces this mission was
part of a destiny 1 DLC you wouldn't
even notice the large amount of - Eden
is - doing friends and the rest of the
content was the only enjoyable aspect of
the news story after running the mission
twice more to unlock the other two
classes it felt like in another story
mission that we've all been playing over
and over for the last three years before
hitting the PvP scene seemed like a good
idea to get to grips with the slightly
new class cars and how to use them so
the obvious choice was to try the strike
with a few friends like the story
mission the environment was great and
the mechanics were flawless
again it was all too familiar as far as
what was shown there was nothing new
that we haven't seen in testing 1 over
the years sure you call additions but it
just didn't feel like it was enough to
make it worth it agonizing wait to get
here definitely more of a chore to
finish the strike and truth be told
there are a streisand isn't wonder a
more exciting
the first thing noticeable was at the
time it takes to kill another Claire has
changed a lot at first this was painful
because we've been playing the crucible
a certain way for the last few years and
that's resulted in a huge change to the
scoreboard however after a few games and
changing classes adjustments were made
and the change was generally appreciated
if it did come with a few drawbacks the
guns felt as though they didn't hit it
hard
well to increase the time to kill a
player that have to make Young's
bleeding less damage you say but this
also affected guns that should be a
one-hit kill like a rocket launcher yet
other gun types like a fusion rifle the
one-hit kill in the right hands this may
be a minor change but is essentially
written off a number of weapon types
ping viable options this major change to
the crucible was put down to making the
PvP element to destiny more competitive
adding more strategy with teams even
before playing the crucible this looked
to be a stupid replacement we are all
for the adding of new game types
particularly the competitive side but
when it comes to casual players is a
huge step backwards the 10 plus hours
put into the deci to invade the crucible
confirms this you're playing with the
team you can communicate a little bit of
strategy and someone back in our command
you can dominate even the most skilled
players just through playing the
objective with our team and we certainly
not pro into the new gaming Network
we're actually doing far better in this
4v4 format than the 66 and destiny one
we could certainly tell when we were
coming up against a team of randoms
because the mercy rule would often come
into effect to properly test this was a
feeling mirro solo play gun as well that
did feel a little bit more even but as
soon as someone dropped out of the game
the wind was pretty much guaranteed in
the opposite team overall the 44 format
was enjoyable but only from a team point
of view sort of an awesome addition to
what was currently available distally
won the Destiny - it'll actually drop
down the number of people who can join
in an obliquely basis new game network
and friends will casually hair of around
5 or 6 people playing each timer on
because work well with destiny won so
with this change to every PvP game
typing 4v4 will probably view
the games the hope is that this comes
down to the maps that were veiled on the
beta but they feel very small being said
that this was done on purpose to add
some chaos to the mix with smaller teams
if this is true then they definitely
achieved this now you can certainly
learn to play to this chaos but it feels
like some of the depth to the old-style
crucible has been lost this new arcade
style of play reaction speed was always
important when playing disney won but
skill and tactic have become less of a
focus they count far less often and do
far less damage this is actually a good
move and too often in destiny one did
fellow Indian members like Bad Kitty
head to the leaderboards with a hell of
a lot a granade million super kills with
only one or two gun kills the gunplay
has been brought back into the game
grenades are still useful and you'll
still have the opportunity to get double
or triple kills with them but you have
to be smarter because not only do they
do less damage but they take a lot
longer to regenerate supers don't feel
very powerful anymore because still
clear out the enemy team but when coming
up against them rather than running some
good team communication you can quite
easily focus fire and get them down so
instead of just popping them as soon as
you see players in front of you you need
to assess the situation
hella likes dying before your super
starting animation is finished again
this is a good move to promote smart
gunplay
those of you that have watched some of
our previous videos may know that one of
our members warm discharged love to get
down and dirty with the analytical side
of these games in the numbers [ __ ]
working at the pros and cons to each
build type and being happy to put in the
thousands of hours of game time to find
the best billet recent situation or
current meter is his forte destiny has
never exactly been a game to excel on
this aspect we're build and even class
diversity is very minimal this is Judith
demographic that the game has been aimed
at lunar shooters are a fairly new game
genre but for the casual call to
hardcore players this is where time is
spent hunting out their perfect piece to
complete that perfect field there are
other games that have done as well the
division for example where no build is
the same the division has many issues of
its own that we were given to in this
video but what it did do well is
something you would never expect it
destiny because of the demographic from
the start of the one seems to have been
aimed at the more casual younger player
base now this isn't necessarily a
problem as there are a bunch of
successful games that don't give this
kind of dip however for a ludus shooter
they need to at least try and get half
way destiny to seems to have gone more
even more simplified than before it's
been dumbed down most of the options
under each classes have been compressed
allowing only a few changes like your
grenade and jump type the new weapon
system moving to kinetic energy and
power weapons has been implemented to
assist in the bounty of PvP the change
and what they're trying to achieve is
understandable however this is severely
limited the weapon options the new
system feels like you have two primary
weapons and one heavy weapon that will
sell renews does it make PDP feel more
belt yes but is it a bit boring only
having a few weapon types to choose from
you bet however the area of the game
that has been most affected is PvE this
is taken an already bland rehash version
of the original strikes and missions and
made them even more boring due to a lack
of variety in the whip
this new weapon system could be the
answer to the PvP balancing issues but
it shouldn't carry over to the PvE
content would make more sense if they
just left the weapons the same in PvE
from the negativity above you may think
they were not fans of destiny but it's
quite the opposite really we're at new
gaming Erica thoroughly enjoyed the
thousands of hours with spin a game and
plan on spending a similar amount of
time and destiny too however after
waiting and waiting for the sequel to
destiny we are expecting a lot more for
PvE it feels as though they've taken a
safe approach and change very little
it's a PvP it seems like we have taken a
huge step backwards in a previous video
you can see where we think testing is
done well and where we think it could
improve overall we see this as a more
simplified version of the game we've
been playing for the last three years
not a breathtaking sequel and said
earlier this is likely down to the
demographic that Bungie is targeting
we're a thousand hours spending the game
by to get a cater player will mean very
little we compared to the far more
casual player in terms of reward and
in-game progress from a business point
of view this makes sense
there's a casual players that make up
the majority of the market but it would
have been nice to see a little more debt
for those of us happy to put in the
hours
destiny is leading the ludus shooter
genre at this stage but as destiny to
the direction that we'd like to see this
genre go with is more simplified more
arcade style of play not at all
hopefully future updates will rectify
the impending problems we have seen it
needs to be said that we've only played
the beta and that Bungie themselves
already said that some changes are being
implemented hopefully they are enough to
make a difference but what do you think
we'd love to hear your opinion in the
comments below
[Music]